bonjour monsieur giguère merci de nous
avoir écrit alors vous j'avais déjà payé
une somme quand même importante pour
aller à ce régime là qui est toujours
pas ouvert exact le club athlétique il a
été exposé d'ouvrir fin enfin à
l'automne début hiver j'ai vu sur
internet qui est un beau jim 9,99 pas
aux deux semaines de super intéressant
pour moi fait que j'ai décidé de
m'inscrire ou début septembre
yves bureau chargé combien et 90 9 pour
pour l'année pour les frais
d'inscription 5 613 d'allocs et j'ai
payé
vous avez déjà payé 213 dollars puis ça
pas bougé est ce que vous venez souvent
c'est ce que ça évolue mais je pense à
chaque joue ici le pour aller au travail
puis aucune construction depuis octobre
je les ai contactés jeudi ce qui va aux
retards de construction
mais après je les ai contactés une
deuxième fois qu' aucune communication
rien il n'y a pas de gens qui n'y a pas
de téléphone peut pas les appeler nom
exact n'a aucune
on peut aussi envoyer un message sur
facebook a pour dessein aucun
aucun homme aucun autre moyen de
communication la savez vous si vous
pouvez vous faire rembourser
je les ai contactés j'ai aucune réponse
encore avec gpa qui comme unique et
vraiment c'est mister puis c'est pas
d'abri matin vous allez vous entraîner
mais non exactes je pensais que ça être
qui va non plus
on va aller voir option consommateurs en
fait très gentil merci beaucoup merci à
vous et listériose option consommateurs
bonjour on vient de rencontrer un
citoyen qui s'est engagé sur le web donc
sur internet à payer un montant par un
jim qui est toujours pas construit à ce
que des recours
bien dans son cas à lui à plusieurs
accords étant donné qu ils conclurent
contre via l'internet
il ya accès à la rétrofacturation à
partir du moment où les services ne sont
pas fournis dans les 30 jours de la date
prévue et ici sur le site web bondi
début de l'hiver présumant que le début
de l'hiver était le 21 décembre
s'ils savaient sont pas fournis dans les
30 jours il peut annuler et s'il envoie
son avis d'annulation
le commerçant doit leur rembourser et si
le commerçant refuse de rembourser ou
négligent de rembourser le comme le
consommateur peut s'adresser à son
émetteur de cartes de crédit pour
obtenir une rétro facturation donc les
émetteurs de cartes visa mastercard port
sont obligés de à ce moment là de lui
remettre l'argent si le commerçant ne
veut pas absolument ils sont obligés de
le faire les délais sont lancés ils ont
90 jours pour le faire
donc la morale en deux mots c'est qu'on
n'a pas reçu service on est mieux ne pas
payer
en fait quand on fait un achat sur
internet aucun commerçant ne peut vous
exiger le paiement avant de vous offrir
le service ou le bien sauf si vous payez
par carte de crédit car c'est le seul
moyen qui c'est le seul mode de paiement
qui vise à sur la protection de la
rétrofacturation quelqu'un qui s'en va
dans le sud un forfait l'aï paix avant
que paul servais oui mais il va payer
par carte de crédit et donc une vraie
cabinet d'yves veut le protéger le
consommateur peut choisir de procéder
par un autre paiement quand il fait un
contrat en ligne il peut choisir de
faire des billets il peut choisir de
pays vers une carte cadeau mais le
commerçant ne peut lui exige
harper mans parade ces modes là à
l'exception de la carte de crédit est ce
que j'aime là vous avez fait des
recherches
ils n'ont même pas de permis en fait en
date d'aujourd'hui c'est le fils de la
protection du consommateur ne recense
aucun permis pour cette gym là donc ils
ne sont pas autorisés à vendre des
services du tout merci beaucoup mais
c'est très clair merci
l'équipe de vie de quartier a tenté à de
multiples reprises depuis plusieurs
semaines de parler un responsable du
club athlétique this de brossard
malheureusement pas de réponse à nos
demandes qui ont été répétés